we have this system of equations here 3t
plus 4g is equal to 6 and we have
negative 60 plus g is also equal to 6.
and there's a bunch of ways you can
solve systems of equations you can graph
them you can solve by substitution but
whenever you see the coefficients on on
one of the terms in this case the t term
and they're
they're almost cancelable and when i say
cancelable if i add 3t to negative 60
you won't be able to cancel them out the
t won't disappear but if i were to scale
the 3 up if i were to multiply it by 2
and it becomes 6 t and then i were to
add these two things then they would
cancel out and i would be left just with
g's so let's try to do that now remember
i can't just multiply this 3t by 2. in
order for this equation to hold true
anything i do the left hand side i have
to do to the right hand side as well so
and i have to do to the entire left hand
side so let me multiply let me multiply
this equation by two so i'm multiplying
it by two so let me just write it here
so i'm going to multiply 2 times 3t
plus 4g
is equal to
2 times 6. anything i do to one side i
have to do the other side the equality
still holds true so 2 times 3t is 6t
plus 2 times 4g is 8g
is equal to 2 times 6 which is 12. so i
really just rewrote the same information
the same constraint in this first
equation i just multiplied both sides by
2. now let me write the second equation
right below and i'll write it in orange
so the second equation right here is
negative six t
plus g
is equal to six
now think about what happens if i were
to add these two equations and remember
i can do that because i'm essentially
adding the same thing to both sides of
this top equation or you could say i'm
this bottom equation because the other
equation is inequality this negative 60
plus g it's it is 6. so if i'm adding 6
to 12 i'm really adding the same
quantity to the left hand side that's
why i can do it so let's add the left
hand sides together when we do that
these six t's cancel out that was the
whole point behind multiplying this
first character by 2 so that the 3t
becomes the 6t and we're left with 8g
plus g is 9g
is equal to 12 plus 6 which is 18.
divide both sides by 9
and you are left with g is equal to 18
over 9 or 2. so we've solved for g now
we can substitute back and solve for t
and we can use either of these equations
let's use the second equation right here
so we have negative 6 t
plus g we just solved for g g is 2. is
equal to
is equal to 6. and we can subtract 2
from both sides of this equation
subtracting 2
the left-hand side of the equation that
cancels out you have negative six t
is equal to
six minus two is four now i can divide
both sides of this equation by negative
six
negative six and we're left with
t is equal to what is this negative t is
equal to negative
two thirds and we're done we've solved
for a t and a g that satisfy both
equations we just saw that it satisfies
the bottom one if you want to feel good
that it satisfies the top substitute
them back into the top three times let's
do that three times the t we got
negative two thirds
plus four times the g we got so plus
four times two let's see what that is
three times negative two thirds that's
negative two the threes cancel out plus
four times two is eight negative two
plus eight is equal to six and that's
exactly what that first equation got us
so these two values definitely satisfy
both equations